Her low freak bitches.
So it's got to be very difficult when you're in business.
When someone like that,
especially like an executive,
some slick character in a fine suit to find out exactly what is real motives
really are the never been fond suits.
Never know how they dress in a polling suits.
Really.
Yeah.
I mean business is never encounter each find suits,
no pockets.
Whereas occasionally you find a t token pocket square,
but you can tell that heart's not in it.
The wife stuck it in there cause she's soul.
Someone on TV that had a bit of razzle dazzle about them and they thought,
oh I and see my old man man,
one of them.
And they sort of stick it in.
The old man's be embarrassed about it and trust squeeze out of the way.
Suits are a thing.
The death of the suit,
it was the death of the suit was the present attitude toward Ongo Noah and I'll
go,
oh,
Larry's name.
Yeah.
I won't put a tie on and on.
Don't want us to count.
That's how I feel.
But that's what's happened.
We've been brainwashed to not dress line gentlemen,
but I see a guy like you and I say,
that's appealing.
Like look how you're dressed and you're in a conservative suit.
This is a nice,
like,
I'm sure you could wear any suit you wanted,
but you chose assert that has a certain look to it.
Yeah.
I have spent some time asking around with this Joe,
but a bit like the same reason that we've spent,
uh,
Tom asking around with a pocket square.
It's,
I remember thinking how much I found the suit repugnant and I became angry that
the suit would be robbed from us.
And so I had to create an alibi,
a way in to understand why is that I'd like to suit this was the magic of Ralph
Lorenz,
the magic of Ralph Lauren,
Nice Jewish boy from New York called Lipschitz,
created a waspy empire.
There's a wonderful expression that,
you know,
think Yiddish,
dress British and Ralph Lauren created this great empire and resold the waspy
world back to the waspy world.
Oh,
you actually not to the waspy.
Well,
because in England there was a sort of resentment about Savile row traditional
tailoring because it'd been robbed from them.
The officers that come along,
the number crunches had come along and there was no creativity in the suit.
A suit needs to be creative.
The person that puts it on calm be putting it on,
but because he's told to put it on,
he's got a one or put it on.
Uh,
so what Ralph did is he fashioned up,
they're sort of [inaudible] new England world and soul.
He took on a trip,
he took on a cliche and he refashioned Ackley Shea to give it a new sense of
life,
a new sense of breadth.
He'd put black people in the suits where traditionally it was just a white man
suit.
He made it feel new.
We gave it a take.
So what he did is he tipped his hat,
the old world,
but also tipped his hat and the new world,
and it allowed wasps to find their way back into the world with an eloquent
narrative.
It was clever.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
okay.